Julie and it's lovely to see you here
today at London Film on comic-con have
you been enjoying it well it's been a
great afternoon been one of the best
I've been to lovely lot of fans quite a
lot of people I've seen before I was
wondering since we talked last time what
do you think pi cells reaction would
have been to the red wedding I sort of
experienced humour I think because he
wasn't involved in it he would not have
felt in the least bit surprised I just
put it that way
he might have disapproved of some of it
I think you usually know when it's only
a little part I know but yeah I think
you usually know when he approves or
disapproves or something but the
audience does but not the people in it
don't necessarily know that well we now
know that two people do now eat up to it
no good well he not too good the good is
saving his own skin but nobody else has
twigged onto that thing yet and so you
can usually tell when he thinks that's
not a very good idea or yes yes yes it
is a very good idea but if I if I
actually go along with him I'll be
alright for the next year or so and I
think you could fairly call him an
opportunist if you were in his situation
in the real world how do you think you'd
fare as pycelle well I I wouldn't be
able to cope with it at all I think I
probably just run away I thought that
all brave with all that violence going
on and the fact that he survived all
that time and he must have started
sometime he must have started I don't
know what his family was probably quite
highborn but he and a clerical position
and he took lessons in how to be a
doctor know that and became quite useful
to people got gradually elevated but
kept his eyes open for the main chance
but never greedy never greedy never
wanted to be king never want to be a
knight or anything like that got
promoted of Grand Master is a promotion
on a sort of civil servant sort of level
there's nothing to do with fighting or
anything like that I've no doubt he was
a bit of a a fighter when he was a young
man he's a very strong man he's got
quite a strong man now how would Julian
respond I don't run away with my tail
between our legs thank you if you could
give myself some advice for season four
and future seasons what would you say to
him keep doing what you're doing because
he's always there and he's an irritant
to people I'm you know the Queen finds
him terribly annoying we just did a
scene it's not giving anyway well it's a
perfectly ordinary scene it's a wedding
scene and and he she just she's a
feeling a bit annoyed that day she just
comes over and Bates pycelle it's just
to annoy him and the King says to test
out you're in a good mood today what is
it
Oh simple pleasures and and just
annoying power supply sell is part of
her pleasure and people do get a bit
annoyed with him okay that's fine but
he's Johnny used for you know back you
don't see it but backstage he's advising
people and helping people and and I know
that Varys that Conleth Hill who's the
head of the Secret Service I know he he
he would use him a lot I don't know
whether he ever will be appear to be
that in the series or not I don't care
I'm in it and I'm not just loved being
in it I love being with those actors and
those directors and those scenic
designers and
really clever writers and yes I enjoy
that if you weren't pycelle on the show
if you could be any other characters at
which character would you like to be yes
I'd like to play Tywin
I'd like to affect I'm too old now but
term that's the part that I would have
played 20 years ago that really tough
not leader a bruiser uncompromising but
very intelligent very good politician
that's the sort I would have paid played
if I've been in Charles dancers position
then but as an old man I'm I'm terribly
lucky frankly to got this I mean it if I
am spared I've got another two summers
work out of it and at my age that's me
to tell you that's something because
there aren't that number of old men
parts about and grow my beard
you mentioned Tywin and he's very good
at maneuvering his family into a good
position on the throne isn't he who
would you like to see on the Iron Throne
though I wouldn't like to see any of
them on it because they're all awful but
him I think you said there's more chance
of people getting a sort of fair deal
with him than with everyone out but he
wouldn't get a fair deal but there's
more chance with him and everyone on
earth absolutely awful but this is why
Oh pycelle you know he just doesn't
defend people and he's not as I said
before he's not scrabbling for the top
position he doesn't want to be king he's
never wanted to be king or anything like
that it want to be a noble but do that
inter marriage thing or have his
daughter up for sale and like they all
are and he's not interested in that I
don't know where they've been married or
not I'm sure he has he certainly works
as if he has as if he hasn't that's the
reason he survives and to think that
someone want one of those people might
be king instead of Joffrey
I suppose anybody's better than Joffrey
because Joffrey is so deeply unpleasant
I was saying to somebody else earlier on
that I think one of the fans that he's
the only he's that the most absolutely
evil person I've ever seen on the screen
because he's not like a a tyrant a
dictator who is politically very
ruthless and in order to keep himself at
the top he deliberately sets out to make
people's life uncomfortable lives
uncomfortable he devises things to make
them uncomfortable either physically or
emotionally and that's what's so
disgusting about him he does it
deliberately doesn't think oh I've got
to get rid of him so I'll get rid of him
he just
get rid of him cut his head off and the
way he the first example getting rid of
Starks cutting his head off which
despite the fact that women pleading for
him and all that and him professing his
decision with the girls think I advise
me very strongly they have a good case
off with his head
it was pleasant for him to do that he
enjoyed that afternoon and so he is I
think we all want him out of the way but
we don't want him to go because it's he
such fun to watch well your I was at
that scene in the first let's say first
serious sorry when he's nearly pushed
over that Battlement and we all went yes
and then the hand came on our shoulder
and she couldn't do it and so here we
are three series later and there he is
still acting awfully nice boy who plays
him you know everyone says how lovely
Jack Gleeson is I really did gentle soft
extremely intelligent Irish man he's
studying to be a philosopher rather a
long way from Joffrey isn't it a very
very long way thank you so much you're
talking to
you